once described as no different to the
vomit of a drunkard
sushi has been on quite a journey the
story of sushi goes back to prehistoric
southeast asia
there fish was preserved by packing it
with salt and cooked rice
resulting in a vinegary fermented fish
and a gloopy rice
the rice part was truly disgusting and
usually discarded
in japan where the technique remained in
use as it died out elsewhere it was
called nare sushi nare meaning aged
this was the definition of sushi for
several centuries but by the 15th
century especially in coastal areas
where fish was more plentiful all year
round
people were leaving it for less time and
daring to eat the rice
which eaten early was pleasantly tangy
200 years later with japanese demand for
the taste of sushi booming
an even quicker version was invented
which involved simply adding vinegar to
the rice to flavor it
finally in the 1820s in what is now
tokyo raw fish as fresh as possible was
added to the rice
now no longer aged at all and modern
sushi was born
the japanese called it higher sushi
higher meaning fast
japan was a very closed country until
1854
so it wasn't until the late victorian
period that westerners particularly
americans started spending time in japan
and encountered sushi
it required an incredible level of skill
getting it wrong wasn't just annoying
but potentially risky
one rare delicacy puffer fish which
today is tightly regulated
is highly poisonous if badly prepared it
wasn't until the 1970s that sushi both
as a luxury treat and
as a cheap street food started to be
seen outside japan
it first emerged in california which had
a large japanese population
and followed the japanese across the
world californians initially aghast at
the idea of eating raw fish grew to love
it
but to encourage them japanese sushi
chefs came up with the californian roll
which originally contained cooked crab
other westernized recipes followed
including the decidedly 1980s
philadelphia rule
with smoked salmon and cream cheese most
western countries don't allow fresh raw
fish to be used because of the danger
from parasites
fish must be frozen which kills the
parasites before use
as sushi spread the deeply ingrained
western fear of raw fish meant that more
and more versions came into use which
relied on ingredients such as cooked
prawns
smoked fish or egg and where the often
complex side sauces were replaced with
simple soy sauce
ginger and wasabi the ultimate
westernization is probably the asian
latin fusion which is the sushi
burrito invented in 2011.
the first sushi restaurant in the uk
opened in london in 1994 in the city the
heart of business land
today sushi is booming marketed as being
healthy
convenient and still just a little bit
exotic
the conveyor belt concept used in many
restaurants adds a certain level of
novelty
as do the chopsticks although according
to many japanese sushi is best eaten
with the fingers
today there are many types of sushi at
its best it is often still
very expensive and very beautiful and
its devotees can be positively fanatical
a japanese apprenticeship lasts at least
five years for a sushi chef
and both japan and the uk have sushi
restaurants which have been awarded
three michelin stars not bad for a food
which started as a way to stop
fish from rotting
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video